the weirdest
song started in my rap career started
made me want to rap and you'll never
think
it's the weirdest song chris brown and
jordan sparks
for real i swear to god
on everything i love where's brown and
jordan sparks
it's um how you supposed to breathe with
no air
eh yeah i used to have my headphones on
them
i used to love i don't know what it was
it was a great song i
jordan sparks from my hometown i heard
that song and i started writing raps to
it
to no air and i i ain't going to lie to
you bro
i can't make this [ __ ] up bro i
literally that song
after i had tapped in and learned about
my father and everything so
i had already been like writing little
raps that was you feeling a little corny
rap [ __ ] i was a kid you feel me
but then that song made me want to take
it serious and i don't know why
no air chris brown and jordan smart i
was an intern
at a radio station when jordan sparks
was american idol but you just age the
[ __ ] out of me so
well i know a lot of you that's crazy
right that's crazy
what was like the first rap album though
that you really like
like hit you like you were like yes
like for me it was doggy style i love
that
it was doggy style and bone thugs and
harmony creeping on a come up
this is tough because i was young so you
got to mind me no for sure but
yeah but at the point when it mattered
it was the card of three that's fair
carter two card three
quarter three carded two yeah i was that
oh eight
that was winning that was when i was
going through the team you know the
training yeah that was when it mattered
so when and that's why like me and like
we'll talk i'll be like lil wayne's my
favorite he's like man you don't know
lil wayne like i know lil wayne and he
right because he feared me
hot boy lil wayne young little wayne you
know black is hot little wayne fire
under the green
one that's [ __ ] whatever carter three's
the [ __ ] carter two
three was i remember my mom she was
saudi i had
you feel me i got that [ __ ] on my mp i
had a little mp3 player mm-hmm
she's like no you're not supposed to be
listening to this right
i'm like no no i gotta get that
that [ __ ] fire i can't go to school not
hearing this [ __ ]
[ __ ]